I want to play a game with you called
Brookfield's best of the best so I know
there's not per se a high school in
Brookfield but it feels very much like
all the characters are very tight it's a
close-knit bond I'm gonna read you your
castmates and you're gonna tell me what
they'd be most likely to or best life
Morgan Cohan most likely to embrace her
weirdness most likely to just be a you
most likely to ask for a very specific
snack from Kraft which is something
healthy good granola bar or an apple or
a salad very very funny she does weird
stuff appreciate she does she's just a
funny person she's like just such an
oddball and there's no shame room and I
love it she's just got this presence in
this grace and everything that she does
like the way that she works and like
just stands and talks it's like there's
just this essence to her that is just so
it's you're just like wow you know I
think that's a unicorn
I saw Queen made her own overnight yeah
so she takes me on Tricia
yeah series yeah okay which is the
fridge full she's good to go she eats
normally in the screen for three months
you can't do it
no you won't be able to take stitches a
corset yeah RJ hot Anaka most likely to
be like Zeus most likely to bring a
notebook everywhere he goes yeah here's
the notebook I don't know what's in it
what I mean is he you think jotting down
the secrets and lies
mmm yes yes very stoic
he's like a mr. congeniality what makes
a mr. congeniality gets along with
everybody the easiest person to get
along with everyone loves him he's
hilarious he's so kind mr. North Bay
there we go 2019 he's so stoic and he's
so dialed in and he's so focused like
just kind of like a like a Greek god
he's got a big presence he can also have
such a small presence as well when he's
in his zone it's cool to watch him work
we like to joke around a lot and so does
he but when it's time for him to dial in
it's like it's go time yeah cuz
sometimes when you take that extra
second to focus there's that little
extra moment that you get that's just
it's gold right when a man runs he runs
for a reason and find out what it is
Jocelin Hugh Todd most likely to put her
dog before all else most likely to play
a prank in the Grad speech she's just a
class clown don't expect it all like
doing some over in the corner she's
hilarious what do I do I'm most likely
to be like Miss Canada she's beautiful
she's but she's also got like a whole
bunch of skill sets
yes like she can just pick something up
and learn it so quickly first time she
got in a horse everyone was like wow
like looks like you've been riding for
years the beauty comes with all the
versatility the dog is adorable
names Rupert he's adorable adorable I
have seen his Instagram yeah well we
posted a photo together Rupert at night
he commented on the photo be like in
Rupert's character of course it's he
loved seeing himself on your celebrity
it's pretty cute yeah has she got many
on you pranks not so much pranks but
just like faces she'll pull our little
dances she does on the side she's great
with the kids too so she's she's just
hilarious she's she is a child in
ourselves she's wonderful Greg Howe
venecia most likely to be at the gym
when I am also at the gym
most likely to be the person I go to for
a nutritional advice really yeah okay so
what have you learned
what's your big takeaway he's very
knowledgeable about that kind of stuff I
mean I haven't double checked his back
so I don't know neuro he's really
stressed he's passionate about it and
and he seems to be really knowledgeable
Gregg is wild I think right off the bat
Wow
but he is so smart and intelligent just
knows about so many different things
most likely to cure a disease while
skydiving on his way to in perfect
together dude
that's a very tall order that's right
but he would do it if someone was gonna
do it it would be Greg are you working
out together by accident yes really
yeah what is it always what is it that
you're doing we have very different
workouts he climbs things very slowly
and then like slowly like a lemur you
know just like Connor moves across and
I'm like I don't know what's that that's
working but you keep doing it
[Music]